hello and welcome everyone to today's uh
cfar virtual
talk this is a series which spotlights
how research from across the academy
from computer science population public
health economics and anthropology may be
used as the basis for evidence-informed
decision-making globally
as governments begin planning how best
to open shuttered economies
sometimes for the second time in the
wake of covid19
if you're not familiar with us cfar is a
canadian-based global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds to address
the most important questions facing
science and humanity
like many others across the globe cfar
has pivoted quickly to take action on
covid19
launching several new projects and
initiatives many of which we're
highlighting through this series
my name is rachel parker i am senior
director of research
at seafarer it's my distinct pleasure to
introduce you to professors
aaron elenov and nama geva zatorski
aaron is a fellow in seafarers humans in
the microbiome program and leads a
research group investigating
interactions between the mammalian host
intestinal microbiota and the immune
system at the weitzman institute of
science
until very recently nama was a cfar
asrieli global scholar in the same
program
she leads a lab at technion where she
studies interactions between gut
microbes and the host immune system in
health and disease
before we begin today's session will
last approximately 30 minutes
i will be taking advantage of my
position as chair today to ask aaron and
ama the first question
they'll discuss their two distinct
approaches to cobit 19 diagnostic tests
before i then open it up to questions
from participants online if you have a
question you can use the q a function to
submit one
we ask that you not use the chat
function to submit questions
lastly this session is being recorded
and will be available
on the cfar website uh next week
nama aaron uh thank you so much for
joining us today
in early march you both pivoted your
research on the microbiome to focus on
covid19 diagnostic tests
can you tell us about that decision in
particular did you have to put other
work on hold
and what have you been doing since then
related to covid testing
so rachel it's first of all it's great
to be here with you and with our
listeners um
and indeed uh our regular work uh uh
evolves around the study of microbes but
but not the microbes related
directly to this epidemic but rather the
bacteria that live within our body
and influence our health and risk of
disease but in early march when
all of us across the world were impacted
with this horrible pandemic we
diverted our efforts in the lab to try
and utilize some of the state-of-the-art
uh advanced uh sequencing and
characterization
technologies that we've been developing
for our gut microbes
and trying to utilize them um against
this horrible virus in improving uh our
ability to screen
and to characterize large populations of
people that
are affected by these hour and um
very similar and uh regular days we
study the gut microbiome as rachel
um mentioned um and uh
at the technion actually in march when
the first um
wave started our labs were closed so we
found ourselves
at home but but as a lab we were like
uh it drove us crazy that we have to
help
somehow and um we brainstormed
around the clock what can we do to help
and actually a couple friends of mine
from boston um uh gave me a kind of a
kick
you should try this method um which is
called
uh lamp and that's kind of worked so
it's uh check upland and the software
although that are now in boston
and uh i quickly
gathered the lab quickly we were all of
us in lab and then
in about two weeks we had the work done
um i can talk more about it later but in
in
briefly it's um a development of a
method
for uh the sars culture detection
fantastic i can elaborate more but
i think i think uh well there are some
uh
lines crossing between both of our
endeavors i think right yours
yeah maybe i'll ask iran to elaborate on
his methods please
sure i think that the common denominator
between
efforts is that the current method for
for
cov19 diagnosis it's a very good one and
it's very robust
it is relatively inexpensive and could
be
utilized across different populations
but this method which is based on a
modality
uh called the pcr or quantitative pcr
also has some limitations and these
limitations
uh are important and and we as a
community need
need to know about them for example um
at least in some cases this this
is a very labor-intensive uh modality uh
many people are engaged in in the
laboratory work uh in order to make it
happen
and um we are increasingly aware that
some of the results that we get from
this uh
conservative or the regular methodology
may lead to either false positive or
false negative
results in other words that you could
have a person who would be diagnosed as
being positive for
corona but in reality if you culture
that person for for the same virus you
would
find that that person may be shedding
their pieces of the virus but not being
really infected
uh uh so that person uh going into uh
you know isolation or part time
would suffer without a real chance
of infecting others and on the other
side of
the other flip of the coin you could
have people that would be declared as
negative but
in fact they have low quantities of this
virus
and they could uh infect their
surroundings um and and the method that
we've been trying to develop um
is based on our uh very advanced
capacity to take large amounts of
microbial
genetic material into sequencing using a
technology called
next generation sequencing and i will
not go into the details because they're
very technical and maybe a bit boring
but what we've been trying to do is to
complement not to replace but to
complement
uh the workhorse system that we we
all are using in covet diagnostics
um in order to enable not to just
diagnose uh the virus based on a single
or two
viral genes that this regular method um
enabled us to identify but to actually
use this more advanced technology
to identify whole chunks of the genetic
material of the virus
and this of course reduces dramatically
your chances of
erroneously uh saying that someone has a
virus while that person only shed
a few pieces of the virus um so this is
one piece of the innovative
platform and the other piece is that
because it is such a
robust methodology that enables to
sequence at once
a large amount of genetic materials you
can
uh utilize it to pull a large group of
people
and to sequence or to characterize their
these people for the virus together as
one uh
as one big sample and if one or two of
the people within this
group of people have the virus then the
this very sensitive technology
would become positive and then you can
test them one by one but if
this entire group would be negative then
you can say that this entire
uh a bunch of people could be declared
negative and this potentially may enable
you to
characterize the whole population and
kind of
tease out the very small numbers of
people that are
actually uh positive uh and in fact
during the development of the system
with characterized using this system the
entire israeli air force
which totals many thousands of people uh
which mostly were negative and we could
identify the very few were positive
and these caps kept this uh you know
infrastructure and
and this group of people uh operational
and going and this is the vision
uh um of of this system um
now i think it's great uh to hear uh the
complementary story uh regarding the
system that
my and her group has been developing
thank you i have a couple of questions
um
i can explain and then we can uh
chat um in our case uh at this point
it's uh
it's individual by individual but we can
uh
indeed indeed marry the pooling uh
technique
uh between us um and uh
this method allows um to
perform the pcr so the pcr that we hear
about
uh that amplifies the genetic material
of the virus
specifically the this virus and um
and see the change by eye
so this um there is an specific enzyme
that
can function in one temperature so it's
an isothermic
pcr we enabled this technique directly
from samples so there's no
reason to have a very elaborated
method to extract the genetic material
of the virus
it can be done by anyone no need for a
professional experience and it since
it's done only in one temperature we
actually
did it in a thermal cup so we
literally spit in a tube then transfer
the material to another tube
uh take water from the end of the
corridor
uh which is hot enough it's kind of a
grandma receipt
recipe like plus minus 65 degrees
and and uh and then
you see the change in the color by eye
from
pink to yellow so one of the questions
um
we were thinking about is to study
epidemics from it and i think your
method is uh
better for this have you thought about
studying uh whether the
genetic because you sequence the genetic
material can you
did you look at lineages and where does
the virus
come from can you see
the trees of the virus from coming from
across the world yeah
yeah absolutely so this is a great
question and if i would to rephrase it
uh the fact that using the next
generation sequencing method allows us
to
sequence an entire let's say nasal or or
or oral sample with all the genetic
material in it
would uh and able to look at the at the
entire or most of the
genetic material of a given virus in a
given person so
what you can do is you can track uh
whether a certain
group of people are infected with a
virus that came from
a certain locality early on in the
disease this was
for example done in order to identify uh
how this uh horrible viral infection
was transmitted from country to country
so if
a sequence related to to a virus in
china was found in italy then one would
assume that
the same virus was transmitted by
travelers from china to italy
and and such a transmission was reported
between countries
what what is now being done um using
technology similar to the ones that
we're using
um is indeed to see whether the virus
itself
with time undergoes changes and this is
very important because this is a virus
that
greatly has the capability to change
its genetic genetic output and this is
important because
we are all fearing that some of these
newly mutated
viruses would become more aggressive or
would change their behavior
and would manifest as a different
clinical manifestation as the original
viruses so so far many people are
monitoring these changes there are
changes
documented uh but we're not sure whether
they are clinically important
at this point but what i would like to
highlight is
that another super interesting advantage
of sequencing an
entire sample with all of these of all
of its genes
is that you're also catching the genes
coming from the human host
not just the virus and we tend to kind
of uh um
you know forget a little bit that it's
not just the virus that in fact
infects the nasal cells in a given
person
it is also that the nasal cells react in
a very unique and personalized manner to
the virus
using our system we are now extensively
looking
at how different people react to the
same virus when they are infected with
this virus
and what was really interesting to us
was to find out
that we can already identify some
signatures
in the host response to the same virus
that may differentiate between
people who will end up being
asymptomatic and would just recover
perfectly safely from this viral
infection to those who would
end up developing a significant immune
response
that would uh result in serious and
at times like risky medical
complications
stemming from the reactivity to the
virus and if this is successful
we may be able to predict which person
would uh have to be monitored very
closely may be
admitted to the hospital and which
person would be
most likely not to develop complications
from the disease
and that person could be just left to
count
his or her quarantined days
at home now uh now
i'll ask you uh regarding your
fascinating method how do you
see this being widely used could you
imagine people using
this really simple room temperature
methodology at home
yes thank you for this question um
i even now without further development i
think it is um
easy to use at home um
it requires just a little bit of
attention
but not much there is a
session in room temperature only 15
minutes and then in
65-ish degrees so it's like
two-thirds of the cup with uh hot
water and then a third with just regular
water and you get
plus minus the right temperature um
but also we are um developing a device
that will
allow even a simple way to detect it so
with the [ __ ] berkovic from the
technion engineering department
which this device will allow just
licking and
clicking the link into the device and
the reaction will
occur so that's under development still
but
we're thinking um that it can be
implemented already and there are
many schools in israel that are in
contact with us to
hopefully next week we will start the
first big
study in a big school in tel aviv
and uh several hundreds of other schools
are interested
and the army as well i think we should
be in close touch because uh for us it
would be great
well we are already but uh for us it
would be great to
adjust the methods according to the
sequences that you find so that
we will uh keep up the evolution of the
virus
how accurate do you find your system as
compared to the pcr
could it replace it or you see it more
as a complimentary
system that would allow people to test
themselves every day just to see whether
something drastic is changing their
viral uh uh
kind of a plus minus diagnosis
yeah it's another great question uh at
this point we're thinking uh
more of a surveillance method it's not
very far from the accuracy
it seems of the regular
um pcr but um it's first
i think it should first go as a
surveillance method and whoever
is cloud positive should still do the
regular qpcr but it's
much uh it's very cheap it's only a
couple dollars per uh reaction
so and people can do it at home so
we believe it's a way to increase the
awareness of who should be really in
quarantine and
who doesn't have to be important and
also catch
uh people earlier like asymptomatic
with a higher viral load
[Music]
you know one of the disadvantages of our
system is that
it takes you know around i would say 20
hours
for a massive amount of people to be
sequenced but but still
it's not immediate as your system so
actually i think that the two
uh systems in development are kind of um
are aimed at solving different unmet
needs in this uh
wide arena um one of the needs
that i think people and countries are
going to have to deal with
very soon um is the the issue of flights
and and international travel uh i mean
in our country which is right now
unfortunately the number one
country uh uh infected with kobe in the
world uh per
uh per million people um there is no
international travel or almost no
international trouble but
economically speaking i think that we
would have to start
living with corona rather than avoiding
travels
during these times because the
implications of economy are devastating
and systems such as yours may be able to
uh help in quickly diagnosing
travelers and making this safe
yeah yeah yeah perhaps we can um
tie between the two as your as you you
said like pooling of many
and then whichever pool is uh
positive tested or yeah or depending on
the
situation like uh yours for surveillance
of uh
high numbers many places at once and
hours for whoever wants to fly
today um agreed
and your uh samples are from nasal the
nasal swabs or have you tried
saliva as well yes
so different samples
uh nasal samples uh oral samples from
the mouth including saliva
um it seems that the nasal samples give
us a bit of a higher
sensitivity but still we can detect the
virus
a body fluids coming from from the oral
cavity from the mouth
uh interestingly enough and it relates
to our
other uh uh interest mutual interest in
life we can detect uh the virus also uh
in the gut we can detect it in stool um
question is whether it is infective uh
in school but for sure
uh this virus seems to affect uh the
entire gastrointestinal tract and
and whether this has a clinical
consequence is an intriguing and
unsolved question
that i think would merit further
clinical research
very cool uh thank you both very much
um so as promised i'm here now to ask
some of the questions from
our viewers at home although we're all
at home
so here's the first question um
aaron how does the cost and turnaround
time of next generation sequencing
compare
to current pcr methods for coronavirus
detection
okay it's a great question because when
you're dealing with sequencing of larger
populations of course the price becomes
a predictive
factor but but since this is a very
um well designed and widely used as
uh modality uh we are able to
miniaturize the
the amount of uh the amount of reagents
that we're using
for this system and to use a lot of
automated robotics
uh to process them and so we estimate
that the price per sample and
it really changes a bit uh with respect
to how many people you want to pull
together
but the price per sample ranges in
around 15
percent which is quite cheap and and uh
if you think of the purpose that it
serves uh this is a price that in most
cases is very cost effective
thanks very much uh norma can you talk a
little bit more about
the limitations to testing people
either who maybe are asymptomatic on the
one hand or
perhaps may not have as high of a viral
load with your chest
yeah uh so with very low viral load we
won't be able to detect
um a couple recent papers came out um
specifying which viral load is the
infective
one and that is very much in the range
that
we can detect so at this point the
viral load that will lead you to
quarantine
in the hospitals we can the very low one
we cannot detect
but the viral loads that we can detect
and the upper limit
that upper and lower limit that we can
detect are still
um way in the ballpark of the
infectious uh period so
yeah so viral loads that are infectious
we can detect but
um very very low ones that are still uh
considered positive
uh we cannot i don't know maybe the
method
i don't know that's that's the that's
the true
answer we're working on improving the
method
and uh i wanted to say that perhaps the
regulations also
uh will change but that's not in my uh
scope so
i have to say that it was really in
cipher we also had many
uh meetings to also like
uh like in my lab and in iran's lab to
see how
uh c4 can help and it was uh really fun
as a
city for global scholar to sit with all
these um
high-end researchers from around the
globe uh like iran and
and and others and uh things together
how can uh
c4 help and think outside the box to
to promote the war against
conflict 19. yeah i i mean
you know in addition to help by see far
i think that the fact that
it enabled uh researchers from across
the globe and from canada to
uh um kind of brace from together for
many years now
uh on issues related to uh bacteria
and to genomics and to anthropology and
the social
aspects of the research that we do um
kind of trained us and enabled us to
think outside of the box in many
different aspects and once the
the kovid pandemic came in and of course
none of us expected it
at the tools and and the camaraderie and
this brainstorming experience
uh greatly assisted all of us in trying
to think out of the box
on how to you know uh harness
uh the knowledge and and the pipelines
uh that we've been utilizing
in other questions uh uh into fighting
their coving so i think that was uh
extremely helpful uh as individuals and
as a safer group
yeah i totally agree and also in the
global scholar there were many
like um inputs and uh trainings that um
help in leadership and networking and
being just part of this human microbiome
group is already
giving a lot of strength and knowledge
so
thank you well thank you both for that
um one additional question maybe to tie
it back
to your program on humans in the
microbiome
um aaron you briefly mentioned this just
at the end of your conversation with
noma
about um the presence of the of the
virus in fecal matter so how might the
microbiota of the gut
affect a person's covenanting experience
do we know
yeah the answer is that we don't really
know it's a fascinating question and the
fact that the virus
is there at least in the gut means that
it may be doing something
we don't really know what it's doing and
one needs to think of the many
challenges of answering such a question
stemming from what we call compounding
factors so for example
the fact that we are all uh or many of
us are staying
at home and changing our diet
accordingly we go out last
means that our dietary habits uh have
been changing and this
reflects very greatly on how our
microbiome
is shaped and how it interacts with our
body so it's not just the virus
in this uh miserable era that is
impacting our microbiome but
many other changes that are associated
with the changing human behavior that
are
impacting our gut microbes i i think
it's an important question because again
it may enable us to differentiate
between people who end up
getting complications from coverage or
not uh but this is a highly
researched a matter that is only
beginning to be teased
uh by different research groups
including our own and around the world
i think we have time for one more
question uh this one is for you noma
and how do you ensure that people at
home are using the test correctly and
can we trust
at home results yeah it's a great
question um
so we are developing an app that will uh
allow you to test yourself uh
both by while picturing yourself so
that's for um
to make sure to trust that you're
testing yourself
uh and also the app will allow to
understand whether the result is
positive or negative without
any individual interpretation because uh
since we're testing the saliva
we do see some changes in the in the
color just because of the acidity
i didn't mention that the change in the
color is um due to acidity that
protons that are released when the
dna is amplified and we have some
acidity sometimes in the
mouth so we can see maybe i will not be
exactly pink but a little bit orange
still there will be a delta when i'm
positive so
when i'll be positive i'll be really
yellow but
for ease and for to ensure it works uh
well
uh the app will be important
thank you very much to both of you and
that is about all we have time for
um we've got about one minute left and
that seems like a terrible time to open
an entirely new question so i want to
thank you both for taking the time to
chat to us today and for the really
important work that you're doing and to
try and get us all
out of the misery that is 20 20. so
thank you very much
and we hope to see you both soon thank
you
very much
you